present the sound award here are jim  hutton and paul apprentice the two kooky  young lovers you met on the beach at  fort lauderdale and where the boys are  i'll be backstage where the girls are  hi  well what do we do now  i don't know let's give an oscar get  back to lauderdale maybe you better read  the nominations first  the nominations are  samuel goldwyn studio sound department  and today oh sound department for the  alamo  samuel golden studio sound department  for the apartment metro goldwyn mayer  studio sound apartment for simron  columbia studio sound department for  pepe warner brothers studio sound  department for sunrise at campobello and  the winner is  the alamo samuel golden sounds  one agent yeah thank you  the samuel goldman sound department  wishes to thank the members of the  academy for this honor that they  bestowed upon us thank you the toddy son  department would also like to thank the  academy and all the members and thanks  again  wonderful